CRISPR is mostly known for making gene editing
so easy, scientists had to pump the brakes
for a second and talk about the ethical implications
of playing God.
But while we haven’t figured out yet exactly
where to draw the line on messing with the
human genome, I think we can all agree we’re
cool with using this revolutionary technique
to mess with harmful bacteria, because we
hate those guys.
Researchers are developing a CRISPR pill which
could help fight bacteria that have developed
a resistance to other forms of antibiotics,
the much feared superbugs.
Best of all, killing bacteria using CRISPR
turns their own defenses against them.
CRISPR is not just how I like my bacon, it’s
also an acronym that stands for Clustered
Regularly Interspaced Short Palindromic Repeat.
It refers to sequences in a bacteria’s DNA
that are pretty much what they sound like,
short sequences that are partially the same
backwards and forwards that are spaced out
regularly.
CRISPR is actually a bacterium’s defense
mechanism against viruses.
That’s right, bacteria get viruses, it’s
a virus eat bacteria world out there.
Anyway, when a virus attacks a bacterium,
it injects it’s DNA into it.
But if the Bacterium has been attacked by
this kind of virus before, it’s saved a
bit of it’s DNA in between the CRISPR strands.
The bacteria will use that as a template to
create a strand of RNA that can target the
virus’ DNA.
Once the RNA is locked on to its friends,
a protein called CRISPR associated protein
9, or cas9 chops up the virus DNA and renders
it harmless.
It’s like an ingenious primitive immune
system.
So scientists thought, “What if we used
this bacterial defense to make the bacteria
destroy it’s own DNA?”
Researchers are figuring out how to do exactly
that, and to add insult to injury, they want
to use a virus to deliver the bacteria killing
DNA.
It takes a little more finesse than just swallowing
a pill of viruses, because stomach acid would
break them down.
So the plan is to shroud the virus in innocuous
bacteria, like a trojan horse.
Once the good bacteria make it through the
stomach, the virus reveals itself before forcing
the bacteria to commit suicide.
Disguised viruses using bacteria’s own weapons
against them for revenge?
It’s like Game of Thrones up in there.
The best thing about this approach is it can
be used to target very specific bacteria,
which is what you want in an antibiotic.
Broad spectrum antibiotics kill swaths of
bacteria indiscriminately, whether they’re
good or bad.
Their overuse has created bacteria that are
becoming more and more resistant to antibiotics,
and if antibiotics become ineffective, that’s
a huge step backwards for humanity.
Remember bubonic plague?
Neither do I, and I don’t want to.
This research has a ways to go before it’s
ready to start busting gut microbes.
The delivery method is in its early stages
and hasn’t been tested on animals.
Plus right now the researchers are just targeting
one species of bacteria, C. difficile.
While C. difficile is a drug-resistant bacterium
classified as an urgent threat by the CDC,
it is just one species, so the same virus
can’t be used to fight other bacteria because
viruses tend to be one-species-only kind of
murderers.
Still, we’re in dire need of new ways to
fight antibiotic resistant bacteria, and if
we can kill them in the most ironic way possible,
I say heck yeah, more research is needed.
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain dot
com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a .com or .net domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
CRISPR’s most well known use is genetic
engineering.
Trace goes in depth on how it does that here.
Are you worried about superbugs or do you
think we’ll science our way out of this
one?
Let us know in the comments, don’t forget
to subscribe, and thanks for watching Seeker.